So this is starting to get it's more than
pathetic.
It's actually starting to get annoying Republicans
and even seemingly some reporters.
Continue to try to shame Joe Biden and really
also his press secretary, Jen Psaki, under
the guise of unity and bipartisanship into
accepting a tiny package from Republicans
on covid relief.
And it's just seems like Groundhog's Day at
this point.
Every day, Jen Psaki is having to tell reporters,
no, I don't want this tiny package from Republicans.
She's rejecting the imposition of this tiny
package every single day that she takes questions.
So let's take a look at some clips here.
Here is Jen Psaki explaining the risk is a
package that's too big.
The risk is that we do a package that's too
small, going through all the trouble of getting
something passed and then it's too small.
That's the real risk.
And we don't want that.
It's an exchange of ideas, an opportunity
to do that.
This group obviously sent a letter with some
outlines, some top lines of their concerns
and their priorities, and he's happy to have
a conversation with them.
What this meeting is not is a forum for the
president to make or accept an offer.
So I think that's important to convey to all
of you and his view.
It remains what was stated in the statement
last night, but also what he said on Friday,
which is that the risk is not that it is too
big this package.
The risk is that it is too small.
And that remains his view.
And it's one he'll certainly expressed today.
Then again, a few days ago, asked about bipartisanship,
why won't Joe Biden consider a smaller package?
Why won't she consider a smaller package of
hers on the Hill?
Appear to already be on reconciliation.
We heard leader Chuck Schumer today saying
that they're moving ahead with or without
Republicans.
Does this undermine your calls for bipartisanship?
And are you urging them to to give this more
time?
Well, for we're all very close to this here,
reconciliation and all the terminology in
Washington.
Everybody who watching may not be a reconciliation
is a parliamentary process.
It's a way to get legislation through.
It's a way to get relief to the American people.
The president wants this to be a bipartisan
package.
Regardless of the mechanisms, Republicans
can still vote for a package, even it goes
through if even if it goes through with reconciliation,
there's no blood oath.
Anybody signs.
This is another good point.
Just because Democrats might end up going
through budget reconciliation to pass without
to pass the covid relief bill without initial
Republican support, Republicans can still
make the call to vote for it.
And what I mean by that is Republicans can
demand a tiny, tiny package as much as they
want.
And Jen Psaki can say, I don't want the tiny
package.
Joe Biden doesn't want the tiny package.
And eventually, Democrats might say it's the
one point nine dollars billion package.
Just because Republicans opposed it during
the discussion doesn't mean that after the
fact, if that's what they ultimately get to
vote on, they can't say, you know, a lot of
my constituents actually like this, I am better
off voting for the larger package rather than
not because I might have consequences with
my constituents if I vote against this thing.
Here is more from this week again about the
size of the package.
Jen Psaki is not willing to give any signal
that Joe Biden will accept package size reduction,
and I'm glad she's being clear about it.
Well.
You said in your statement that the scale
of what must be done is large, but the bottom
line is six hundred eighteen dollars billion
is considered large by the White House.
Well, I think our statement last night made
clear that the president believes that the
risk is not being to going to small, but going
going not big enough again with the small
packages.
What if it's too big?
The issue is it being too small.
And I have to tell you, in a sense, there
are already Democrats have already decided
instead of doing 2000 more dollars, they want
to do fourteen hundred more dollars, which
would combine with the 600 from December to
total 2000.
That's already smaller than what was promised
by Joe Biden right around the time of the
Georgia elections.
They've already conceded.
And I think that this is important, even coming
to the table with fourteen hundred instead
of 2000 per person is already a shrinkage
for lack of a better term in terms of the
package size.
Here's another one from yesterday.
Again, reporters playing to Republicans who
say, oh, it's too big, is too much money.
The president's bottom line is that this is
a package.
The risk here, as he has said many times,
is not going to too big.
It is going to small that it continues to
be his belief.
And that's why he can he supports the efforts
by Senator Schumer, Leader Schumer and Speaker
Pelosi to move this package forward.
My sense is that this is not going to stop
any time soon, so.
As I've said yesterday, pass the larger package
and do it with or without Republicans, if
Republicans really want to vote no, let them
say it's bad.
Let them vote against and let them explain
to their constituents why they didn't want
to deliver a package of this size to them.
And then constituents can decide, does this
person really have my best interests in mind?
And when it comes to the members of the House
of Representatives in under, you know, what
is it at this point?
We're talking about 22 months.
Insane, right.
But in 22 months, those constituents can decide
to either reelect or not their representatives
who may reject the one point nine trillion
dollar stimulus package.
I think that for Democrats, this is very much
a risk worth taking.
And I would like to see them just say this
is enough.
Joe Biden had the meeting.
These 10 Republicans are obsessed with tiny
packages, and that's all they kept proposing.
Jen Psaki rejected the advances of the tiny
package.
Joe Biden does know it's just time, guys.
It's time.
They've already delayed and they've already
reduced the package size.
I hate that this happened.
But Democrats have already they sort of negotiated
against themselves.
And what I mean by that is Joe Biden said,
I support and if OSF and Warnock win, we will
immediately send out two thousand dollar checks.
It didn't happen immediately.
And they're only talking about fourteen hundred.
That's the negotiation.
Democrats as as they often do, negotiating
against themselves.
That's it.
No further negotiation.
Let's move forward.
Pass it via budget reconciliation.
We were there were questions about Joe Manchin.
From what I read over the last 24 hours, Joe
Manchin is going to go for it.
He will vote for the package.
So it's time to do it.
I would like to see it done within twenty
four hours.
I don't think that's going to happen.
Maybe 72, maybe 96.
Let's stop this nonsense.
Let me know your thoughts about it.
Package size and all.
You can find me on Twitter at
David Pakman.